alors Véronique on était tout à l'heure
à Versailles avec le salon écrire à
Versailles on va y rester parce que vous
allez nous parler pour commencer d'une
librairie indépendante qui participe à
une opération originale tout à fait
plusieurs même enfin une originale et
une plus classique je vais vous raconter
ça alors c'est le livre bleu qui se
trouve rue de Montreuil à Versailles
voilà une librairie indépendante donc
elle s'est dit même très dynamique elle
organise évidemment des rencontres
littéraires dont celle de dont je veux
vous parler c'est le jeudi 1er juin à
18h30 avec l'auteur Timothée de Fombelle
qui est un auteur très connu très connu
aussi des adolescents pour ces livres
tobylonnaises Vango etc donc voilà donc
comme ils attendent beaucoup de monde
la librairie de Viroflay une page de vie
et donc le livre bleu se sont associés
et ça va avoir lieu à Viroflay cette
rencontre à l'auditorium de la
médiathèque pour accueillir la foule
voilà donc jeudi 1er juin 18h ça c'est
pour l'opération originale on va dire ça
c'est la plus classique comment dire
entre les deux
ensuite voilà le plus original qui
arrive il se trouve que la librairie du
LIVRE bleu imaginez-vous est une
librairie test parce qu'elle a un client
un jeune homme qui habite le quartier
Christophe de Rouy qui vous interrompt
très rapidement il faudrait vous mettre
un peu plus en face de votre micro parce
que les téléspectateurs ne vous
entendraient pas Véronique et ce serait
bien dommage de ne pas vous entendre
voilà c'est du direct c'est aussi la
magie du direct donc on parlait de cette
opération plus classique autour de cette
librairie là une opération plus
originale que vous étiez mettre notre
connaissance quand à notre connaissance
alors du coup Christophe de Crouy qui
est un jeune développeur dans dans
l'Internet voilà a eu l'idée de mettre
en de créer une application comme
vintage pour les vêtements devintd pour
les livres parce qu'en fait ce qui
choquait c'était que quand vous achetez
un vêtement sur vinted vous avez le prix
de l'envoi et le prix de la Commission
du site qui quelquefois font que c'est
encore plus cher que l'objet lui-même
bref donc lui il fait ça complètement
bénévolement il a envie de tester et
donc il est en partenaire avec le livre
bleu donc sur Internet vous avez sur
leur comme une bibliothèque
virtuelle vous pouvez vendre vos livres
ou vous quand vous mettez le Jungle on
vous donne le prix du livre neuf c'est à
vous d'évaluer le prix du livre
d'occasion après et donc le livre bleu
sert de relais vous apportez vos livres
qui ont été achetés par d'autres
personnes et les autres personnes
viennent rechercher le bouquin qu'elles
ont acheté
exactement donc jamais trop donc bah
voilà Christophe decroé a fait ça il a
déjà 100 personnes inscrites enfin qui
sont actifs sur son site et il existe
que depuis trois mois donc c'est pas mal
et il espère un jour proposé cette
application à d'autres librairies de
quartier lui il est très attaché à sa
vie de quartier et on le comprend voilà
donc ce que je voulais vous dire pour le
livre bleu avec vos insolites je disais
tout à l'heure vous êtes l'une des
influenceuses des Yvelines on peut le
dire Véronique
on recherche justement des influenceurs
nouvelle génération peut-être quand même
donc à au shopping grand plaisir voilà
c'est le premier casting il recherche
des à mettre des cherche à mettre en
avant des des futures influenceurs parmi
les clients du centre commercial ou
parmi les habitants autour du centre
commercial c'est du 30 mai au 7 jours
donc cette semaine vous pouvez donc vous
inscrire pour de ce concours et il faut
pour participer à avoir 18 ans bien sûr
créer deux stories sur Instagram et
Facebook sur 24 heures en citant deux
boutiques du centre commercial et un des
services du centre commercial bref et si
vous passez ce premier tour après il y a
un second tour faudra proposer un réel
et qu'est-ce qu'on gagne alors c'est pas
tout ça on gagne des conseils du
influenceuse de prestigieuse que vous
devez connaître elle est des Yvelines
elle s'appelle Tinka et elle a 267
000 abonnés sur son compte insta vous la
connaissez7000
voilà c'est du live style et donc elle
va coacher les deux gagnants et en plus
c'est de gagnant auront 1000 euros en
carte cadeau à dépenser évidemment dans
le centre commercial en question voilà
et on termine Véronique avec la Fête de
la Nature clôture à but et cetera
voilà et d'ailleurs donc demain il reste
une manifestation qui donc dans ce cadre
de la Fête de la Nature et qui est
consacré à des au seul mammifères
volants qui sont extrêmement précieux
c'est à dire les choses souris qui n'ont
pas toujours une très bonne très bonne
image mais qui sont en fait des petits
mammifères adorables et surtout très
très précieux parce que ce sont des
insectivores écologiques en fait une
chauve-souris combien elle peut avaler
de moustiques en une nuit à votre avis
allez dites moi chef des tonnes non pas
des tonnes on va peut-être pas
c'est déjà très bien alors du coup c'est
une manifestation manifestation pardon
qu'elle lui a joué un Josas donc demain
à 20h45 c'est un spécialiste des
chauves-souris quand un Rui qui qui
anime ce cette rencontre et c'est une
petite balade à la découverte de ces
bestioles on va on va aller voir et on
va apprendre plein de choses c'est à 20h
et à partir de 8 ans ça peut intéresser
les enfants et donc elles sont un peu en
voie d'extinction malheureusement enfin
pas d'extinction est un peu fragile car
elle manque d'habitation maintenant il y
a moins de vieux arbres avec des trous
il y a moins de grottes de baraques
exactement donc peut-être qu'il va
expliquer aussi comment leur proposer
des nichoirs parce que ça existe et
elle joue un rôle essentiel dans
l'écosystème évidemment et c'est
important de leur redonner en quelque
sorte leur lettre de noblesse vous
l'avez dit elles ont pas eu forcément
bonne réputation très dernièrement avec
le covid covid 19 notamment où elles ont
été un petit peu ciblés au début de
cette épidémie et on en a bien besoin
parce qu'elle mange des moustiques et
elle régule en fait les populations
d'insectes donc voilà merci beaucoup
Véronique qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu un
insolite ce qui vous a plus intéressé
que d'autres je crois que les livres
style vinted bizarre non oui des livres
merci en tout cas Véronique pour tous
ces employés pour on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec plaisir